vous connaissez les smartphones qui
expliquent est-ce que vous savez comment
ils viennent tester le nombre de fois où
ça peut se plier ou pas et bien c'est
une machine qui vient les plier les
déplier les plier les déplier les bref
plus de 200000 fois ici on nous marque
mais on sait qu'il était beaucoup plus
300000 fois 400000 fois une visée au pot
il y a pas longtemps et bien ici on est
sur le stand de Samsung display et
Samsung display monte cette machine je
trouve ça une fois de plus intéressante
pour déjà d'une vous assurer quand on
consommateur et bien cette technologie
est fiable et vous permettra de l'ouvrir
un paquet de fois pendant 5 ans sans
aucun problème ça c'est la première
chose et puis la deuxième c'est de voir
s'il y a des points de chauffe ou pas
parce que vous quand vous allez l'ouvrir
d'aller ouvrir une fois deux fois trois
fois mais pas tout dans toute la journée
ici il ouvre 200300 400000 fois la suite
donc ça va créer forcément un peu plus
de friction un peu plus de chauffe et si
ça chauffe et si ça s'abîme ils le
verront tout de suite je trouve ça
marrant de voir ces technologies comment
est-ce qu'ils viennent travailler en
coulisses et que nous montre ici et que
moi je puisse vous le retransmettre
parce que vous avez déjà vous un
smartphone qui explique est-ce que ça
peut vous intéresser est-ce que vous
êtes plus sur de l'enroulable du pliable
marquez moi ça dans les commentaires et
puis bien évidemment on va continuer à
en parler parce que c'est une
technologie que je trouve absolument
intéressante passionnante et puis c'est
une technologie d'avenir voilà pour ce
que